hi in this video we will talk about the
quran flexes and the CSF system CSF
stands for cerebrospinal fluid
cerebrospinal fluid is circulating all
around our brain and even in the spinal
cord and it works like a protective
cushion which protects our brain from
any kind of mechanical damage imagine
somebody is hitting you hard in the head
or you are hitting your head in a rod in
that situation your brain is sitting
inside your cranial cavity and your
brain does not - around your cranial
cavity because the CSF system is
protecting your brain and preventing
from any kind of mechanical damage but
other than protecting from any kind of
mechanical damage or maintaining the
intracranial pressure the cerebrospinal
fluid and Quran Texas system has many
other role to play it turns out that
cerebrospinal fluid has many growth
factors and micro rna's which helps in
neurogenesis and maintains the
progenitor state which would be
important for producing neurons in the
brain
now cerebrospinal fluid is not mixed
with the blood because there is a blood
CSF barrier and the Quran makes us
epithelial cells form the blood CSF
barrier which is very similar to the
blood-brain barrier and this blood CSF
barrier ensures that harmful substances
does not enter the brain color Texas
also works like a gateway for immune
system in the brain specially
macrophages and any other immune system
invade the brain vehicroid mixes other
than that kurai plexus has been an
important fluid for a disease biomarker
or for disease diagnosis in case of many
neurodegenerative diseases and bacterial
or fungal infections the CSF biomarkers
would be a good thing to diagnose now
let's look at the choroid plexus and the
left and the ventricular system in the
brain so
we know that inside our brain there are
three ventricles and the CSS flows from
the lateral ventricle to the third
ventricle via the foramen of Monro from
the foramen of Monro from the third
ventricle
the CSF travels the fourth ventricle
from the cerebral aqueduct and this is
how the whole from in the whole brain
the CSF is circulated now the CSF is
produced from the choroid plexus which
is an epithelial tissue lined by several
blood vessels and that's why the name
plexus Quran plexus lines the boundary
of these ventricles and there are three
distinct anatomical locations for the
choroid plexus first the Quran fixes of
lateral ventricle which are lining the
lateral ventricles the Quran plexus of
time Cephalon or the choroid plexus
which is situated at the roof of the
third ventricle and lastly the Quran
Texas of the hindbrain which is situated
into the fourth ventricle now all of
these choroid plexus have a overall
similarity that all of them have the
epithelial cell and innovated by several
blood vessels but in terms of molecular
heterogeneity they are pretty different
from each other and they have unique set
of genes which are expressed which are
important for their functional attribute
but we are not going to go that much
details in this overview it turns out
that Quran flexes and it's function to
produce CSF and many other associated
functions are pretty much conserved
throughout many species especially the
rodents the primates and higher primates
now let's look at the developmental
timeline of all of these karai plexus so
the first chord lexis to develop is the
hind brain choroid plexus or the fourth
ventricle choroid plexus followed by the
fourth ventricle karate mixes the
lateral ventricle choroid plexus develop
almost simultaneously and the last
chloride makes us to develop is the hind
brain curve is the diencephalon occur on
Nexus or the third brain cortex third by
all right mixes now Korat plexus has
blood supply and these blood supply to
the lateral ventricle choroid plexus
comes from carotid and the middle
cerebral artery whereas the posterior
parietal artery supplies blood to both
the lateral ventricle choroid plexus and
the diencephalic chloride mixes and the
posterior inferior cerebellar artery
supplies blood to the hind brain choroid
plexus now let's look at the signaling
pathway how choroid plexus development
takes place the signaling mechanism
behind it so current mixels development
is pretty interesting because from the
stem cells could write plexus develop in
one hand side which is majorly
epithelial in nature and on the other
hand side there is development of the
neuron which is a different lineage the
question is how this lineage is
bifurcated and how this lineage is
maintained because choroid plexus
epithelia sits like an island in a sea
of neurons so how the epithelial
identity is maintained and the neural
identity is suppressed is a big question
it turns out several signaling molecules
such as bone morphogenetic protein BMP
winds etc give important signaling fuels
which allow these progenitors to become
epithelial in nature but if you don't
have BMP signaling then alternative fate
is chosen instead of becoming us alright
lexis epithelium it becomes a neuron
instead so this is how we understand
that the development of the parietal X's
is finally orchestrated by morphogen
signaling now in human caride Peyser
color plexus development takes place
from gw5 to gestational b12 and in this
term quadratic cells grow in size as the
age progress for example here you look
at a embryo of GW 12 here you can see
the kuroi plexus is pretty big
and spending all around the ventricle
almost occupying all the real estate
inside the lateral ventricles now we
come to the cell types that are present
in the correct places
Vocaloids plexus is majorly made up of
epithelial cells there are many other
cell types of course there are
epithelial cells but there are parasites
endothelial cells macrophages and even
neurons neurons constitute very less
amount like 5% of the total cell types
present in the choroid plexus and they
come from the nearby Rafa nucleus and
this is still hypothetical and not much
evidences are bear but neurons are
present in the choroid plexus anyway
let's look at the site or architecture
of the choroid plexus all of these cells
are ciliated and they're epithelial in
nature they are cuboidal their nucleus
is basically placed and in between them
there are adherence Junction there are
tight Junction which forms the blood CSF
barrier ensuring the substances which
are leaking from the blood cannot enter
the CSF and this is the epithelial
barrier the endothelial cells of the
blood vessels they are loosely packed
and they are not backbite tight tight
junctions so they are pretty much leaky
in nature but all the tight Junction
proteins such as occluding loading zone
of clearance etc ensures that nothing
can move from the blood to the CSF and
the backward flow is also prevented and
this is how the Korat press correct
lexis forms the blood CSF barrier and
protecting our brain from the harmful
effect of several metabolite toxic
metabolites or other pathogens now CSF
production takes place in the choroid
epithelial cell and the ii proportion or
the keep portion of the CSF is actually
water and that water is secreted and the
water is actually a filtrate of the
blood now the blood cannot be directly
secreted into the CSF because the blood
cannot move
through these tight junctions so there
are several iron channels presenting the
epithelial cells which allow ionic and
water transport these ion channels
include sodium potassium chlorine by
bicarbonate Co transporters bicarbonate
Co transporters potassium channels etc
but major ones are the sodium potassium
ATPase aqua pouring water channel which
secretes the water into the CSF and a CC
for potassium channel which is a
potassium and chloride cotransporter all
of these are present in the apical side
whereas in the basal lateral side there
are other anion exchanger and
bicarbonate exchanger present so all the
epithelial cells of the choroid plexus
has a apical basal polarity and this is
very important in terms of CSF
production so now once once we looked at
the machinery of the PSA production
let's move on to understand what happens
if the Quran plexus produces too much
CSF or what happens in the CSF volume
increase one of the possible
pathological situation is hydrocephalus
but the ventricular volume is increased
dramatically and it leads to a huge
cranial pressure in tho and it is pretty
much common in many infants in that case
there are specific ventricular shunts
which are used to drain excess fluid
from the ventricles other than that in
case of patients of epilepsy were having
seizures or in case of person who is
having an Alzheimer disease their CSF
has distinct biomarkers or their CSF
composition is very different from a
normal CSS so CSF can be also a source
of biomarkers and detection of many
diseases so that is how CSF is a very
important body fluid I would say not
only these kind of neurodegenerative
diseases but in case of bacterial fungal
and viral infection but the appearance
of the si si of the protein content
glucose content etcetera changes so
looking at the composition of the CSF
one can predict what type of disease has
happened that is why CSF composition is
very important and testing CSF is widely
accepted in the medical community other
than that karate
has a role to play in circadian rhythm
which is revealed very very recently and
many other interesting and intriguing
function of the Kuran plexus are yet to
be revealed so I hope you enjoyed this
video about karate excess and
cerebrospinal fluid which is a
neurophysiology video so if you liked
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you guys for thanks for listening